don't start I know don't start I know I
didn't I don't start
uh so
I sat by myself
and watched it in its full entirety part
one and part two last night
it's it's all of our story
it's just played out differently but
we're we're all daughters
and we're all people who
are just trying to get through life you
know
but I think that you and I have taken
such incredible accountability for our
lives we've never put the blame on
people we act strong and not broken or
victim like that has always been our
narrative I know and you know that that
you can't teach somebody that you know
you really you can't teach that you we
started so young
that we we never had like anonymity and
then Fame we were babies you were baby
like it was like so there's you learn
you have different techniques and you
learn it and then you start being
thankful for so many of the good things
that do happen and then you you fight
you fight to make that who you are
rather than the sitting there and
feeling victimized or blaming or it's
such a waste of time plus we both had
mothers who we needed to navigate and
keep alive and take care of yes and they
were broken they were both scarred and
broken and then these babies come alive
and they're like it's it's it changes
their whole life
but it doesn't heal them
you know I love that you say our story
is everybody's because I always say that
too it's small town it's high school
it's all relative it's like you can make
our sort of open book life applicable to
anyone I really believe people are
living up to expectations whether
they're from our family our fathers
mothers we we're all are aspiring to get
approval from our mommies and daddies
like you either spend your life running
away from running towards trying to not
be like trying to be like your mother
and it's it's Primal and you've got to
go through the process of it and it's
just a lot of work
this is going to seem like a very weird
turn but
like how did you feel about the metoo
movement in the sense of
I didn't feel
like I had a dog in that race I didn't
feel like I could speak to it because I
experienced so many things that were so
inappropriate at such a young age that
I'm so confused about what was I
accountable for what did I put myself
into where was I was I a part of things
we were children how did that Movement
Like affect you did you feel like you
could speak to it
no because I didn't know where I fell on
the spectrum of it like I I don't know
where to interpret my my experiences
because I was made to feel culpable
and by the same time
you know you you you victim shamed
yourself
you know and that's but we were so young
and it was so appropriate I know that we
just you know I don't I couldn't feel
sorry I didn't even know I didn't know
what it was I didn't know
and so when it was called out to me as
such
I was like nope uh-uh no uh uh no not
going there it did not happen that did
not happen that's exactly how I felt I
felt like I couldn't speak to the
movement and I was so happy that it was
happening but I felt like I experienced
too many things that were so gray and
and so awkward and that I didn't know
were wrong at the time
I guess as an adult with hindsight yes
as a mother of daughters the mother of
daughters I think that's what helps with
the perspective of it yes but but the
ownership of it or the ownership of the
reality of it that never was in my I I
did not know how to handle any of that
so I just pushed it under the rug like I
didn't
it didn't oh I'm going to lead to
another weird pivot of confusion but
when I'm watching the documentary and
Andre Agassi
is watching you do the friends moment
and he goes home and he is so rageful
that he destroys everything that's
meaningful to him every award that he's
won his Awards he destroyed Wimbledon
the open everything every important
trophy he destroys I never speak to the
fact
that a huge part of why I'm single is I
don't want to hear it anymore for men I
don't want to hear you
how dare you be sexual at work how dare
you that is so many of the relationships
I've been in and I've never heard
someone talk about that you try to do
your job during the day and you go home
at night to a man who doesn't know how
to deal with it and I do nothing but
then empathize with them and try to make
it okay for them you're doing the show
again you're starting you're putting
you're winding up the battery let me be
smaller so you can feel bigger but I
mean you know that stuff starts from
when we were little like my mother
commanded more attention why was she in
every interview with you
[Music]
foreign